podcast man special guest in here Hazard
I've been seeing you do your You
Freestyle every Friday 40 ounce Fridays
right yeah we drop every single Friday
how many weeks straight have you been
doing this 211 now
200. so how many years is 200 that's
four four years straight yeah
yeah do you like how do you I mean God
Bless you that's great at this point
it's like Bree I mean I'm sure like with
you how long you've been running your
show for sure I'm saying so it's like
it's what I do so it's like um it's just
kind of part of it we've had some like
bumps along the road you know covet and
whatever the case was where you from I'm
from Ontario originally okay
yeah yeah to the IE man yes sir Ontario
is a Vibe out there yeah I could show an
airport yeah Toyota Center yeah
absolutely yeah what team y'all got
y'all got some sort of minor league team
out there right yeah so we got well we
got two now I'm a Laker fan but they do
got the Ontario Clippers and then um the
uh Ontario Reign which is like the minor
league team for the Kings oh fire yeah I
with on I with the IE man
shout out to the IE shout out to hazard
in here go follow material before you uh
do what you're about to do yeah yeah put
your IG
um at IMA Hazard the letter I the letter
M the letter A h-a-z-e-r-d e-r-d yeah
let's get right to it man hazard in the
building come on
yeah
[Music]
it says
let me get right to it
look
they're saying I'm the next thing for me
he candles out the West I put my people
on my back a whole close up on my chest
I wrap them both from prison Inc I got
to catch and wreck when it's embedded in
your flesh it's a different type of
stress so zip it up quick watching the
uptick and then stick up kids gonna let
that stick up quick find out it was your
that sick with a big butt
head to me in the dream was when you was
getting your dick suck you hop up in
your pickups ready to pick the clip up
and lean them off the hollows and
Hawkins off of the sick up twist up your
fingers will you let them bullets fly my
people don't die we immigrate across
borders and multiply insulted by anyone
thinking that they might equal I'm the
one still talking Desert
Eagles couldn't ride my way with a
boogie board a receiver I'm just
on these rappers they shouldn't
have fed the seagulls
this debate about the illness Brown
rapper is stupid who else got hot when
he dropped with his own movement 40
ounce Fighters is really my institution
I've been pushing in peace not pimping
the prostitution
is using he be dropping them bars all
for them all to do with assault what
they charge to pull with I had to hop in
the booth quick make a slick play and
switch things cause made
talk to Cops and cuts off
a switchblade it's forever snitch King
tomorrow and yesterday middle finger to
that rainbow the pros hope your
cargo kick Click Boom in the garage how
soon they regard damage of an informant
then two face statements hit harder than
George Foreman buying without
forewarning or Palm in the 4-4 then I
hopped in your four door I said mine you
said no more that's when I caught my
first carjacking cards b-e-t uncut
moving hard after dark hit the county
started stacking bar after bar sticker
kid Bullseye when I'm targeting Mark
spit dark after dark gonna Dodge car
spend a lot of time in back of a squat
car I'm talking to the youth the hooded
is not yours we don't own apartment
house or even a pot store they legalize
the tree they shout out to cookies has
it your best bet kept calling up my
bookie let me get a thousand or has it
Making a Splash you know we taking it
back when skills was paying and rap yeah
yeah man let me get another one
okay let me get another one
hazard
whoa
let's get toy
okay
it's like what do you say something like
hands to the mic after I eat every year
knowing to kill tracks and then cause
Mass Hysteria
look
yo
I do this for the Edgars and the homies
Little Rock a flannel black and out on
Beats like I never bought the Dodger
Channel I crossed my competition like I
got a lot of handles competition cross
me hey your family lot a lot of candles
I'm out the city but your situation
he sick some bad boys on you like my
name was P Diddy I left some riders that
usually roll with me got a home invasion
plan right around 450. it's looking like
Point Break in your residence they need
the dope straps and all of the Dead
Presidents and I ain't even have to lift
my thumb my belly had to clip my tongue
and they grip their guns listen with a
little effort out to never to Forever
never thought you'd get jacked now
forever you're in heaven I call shots
but I don't need no help cause I don't
get nothing done I wouldn't do myself
let's rule once with you thinking that
I'm go ahead and try to push me
and find out I'm not a rookie yup so if
it's War then you see that I'm a general
imma you harder than a Playboy
centerfold let me guess you wearing the
cave that's got bullets in excess that
might be your best bet now you said you
knowing it for a fact but him armor
piece and rounds will make you rethink
that so think fast get to ducking and
dodging thought he saw him leap frogging
but he still racked his nugget that
infrared is a convenience and I love it
I just push a little button in the
moving targets nothing stop front and
stop playing straight up before you're
done like Pig's skin gets stitched and
laced up face up highs open in the
street couple shells on the chest Barrel
smoking on the heat even worse while I'm
dope on the beef and fresh Coke off for
leaf from Stella soldier with the piece
look there's never been a real a rapper
in the game why the hell you think these
bastards gave me Hazard for a name come
on whoa yo give me another one okay okay
um hazard
yeah
look
yo
I'm killing rappers two for one like
aborted twins dog I'm the
where's the porcelain y'all rape a
double time delivery and force it in I
get consent over 84 bpms sadistic lyrics
just torture man with the force of pants
and put your to rest
cavarky I leave this beat well done
stick a fork in it and no salons alaikum
with and pork in it guppy rappers
are born losers I'm forced to win should
I swam with the sharks I need a dorsal
fear I'm a junkyard dog and use a
Yorkie's can you on Shack in 92 and you
assorted rims they say the rap game
filthy is a junky skin well I'm a
hypodermic needle let me in
consider this your only warning if you
test my pen I crucify resurrect and put
you to rest again oh damn
we knocking over knocking peace off
I had to go follow him online uh what's
your IG one more time yeah I'm A Hazard
the letter I the letter M letter A
h-a-z-e-r-d go follow him man yeah
down baby you already know shout out to
Bootleg bootleg Kev podcast hey I know
you just watched the new free freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to L
Dash R Dash g.com use the promo code
bootleg save 30 off at checkout you get
this for this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-d-g.com promo code bootleg and save
30 off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week